when jordan and i get together
we'll just get together over coffee and
just chat and talk and most of the best
conversations that i've ever had with
people are the conversations that i have
just chatting over a cup of coffee and
it's where the real connection happens
and i thought letting people in on that
would just be an unbelievable experience
we've never done anything that's
remotely like this this is something
completely different it's how i talk to
my friends when you go out for coffee
and that's the kind of conversation i
think people want to hear you're going
to see me talk on this show with people
that i'm friends with people who i talk
with all the time but off air is not the
same as on air you're gonna see what our
conversations are like when we're not
sitting in a in a set that was built
just for me to ask questions with lights
in the background or anything like that
it's gonna be a fly on the wall way for
you to participate in a conversation the
kind of conversations that i have with
with deeply influential brilliant people
who have affected my thinking i hope
i've affected their thinking you're
going to get see us go back and forth
talk about our families talk about our
lives and and talk about the deepest
issues in life and listen i love talking
to jordan over coffee i can't wait to do
this again with with other people i know
people who i consider to be friends
people who you might not be able to see
behind the scenes the whole draw i think
of this show the thing that makes this
show special is going to be the fact
that you're going to get to be the fly
on the wall when i talk with some of the
most interesting people on the planet
you should go check it out over at
dailywire.com also at the daily wire app
it's the only place you're gonna be able
to get the full conversations and they
really are full-fledged long in-depth
conversations with some of the highest
iq smartest and most interesting people
on the planet
you